mm go and read Maya and welcome to on an
actual Friday we did it brows we did I'm
proud of you you didn't do [ __ ] but
still so I just got back from LA as some
of you know I've been in there attending
VidCon where I met a ton of you rows and
it was a good time it was really nice so
long fight though and I'm super tired
like I'm so jet-lagged still but I know
you both wanna marry out so you [ __ ]
up I thought we're gonna do something
that mostly girls don't YouTube which is
like tags or whatever and this one is
called 25 things that you didn't know
about me so I'm gonna select 25 things
that you might may or may not know about
me but and you probably didn't care to
begin with and stuff but I'm gonna
select five of them that are fake so you
can guess along which are true and which
are fake you can post your comment of
what you thought and then you check the
link in description ll I'll show I'll
show the answer there and to be extra
awesome anyone who participates might
win a razor razor blade laptop I think
it's pretty cool that they're sending
one out I'm not asking for likes or
anything okay
so here we go 25 we got a hurry I don't
eat vegetables I got a poker face my way
through this my favourite holiday was
visiting at the Caribbeans why would I
ever lie about that I know how to sail a
boat
I get so seasick if I get on a boat that
I will I want to fit a walk in my mouth
and then I swallow it it's pretty hot my
favorite band of all time is Radio hand
I am a compulsive liar
see what I did there I played electric
guitar for six or seven years I was
pretty good I was a solo guitarist had
some videos of you to put I know it
could be a lie you don't know where
anything okay when I was 14 I wandered
district championship Oh in tennis
I have never twerked upside-down I used
to study industrial economy at the
University when Miley Cyrus twerk I
throw up a little bed in my mouth every
time my dad gets just as scared as me
from horror movies if not more scared I
get my nerdy side from my mom I have one
sister and one younger brother I
secretly wish I was part of one
direction I started YouTube from that I
sold artworks from that I made in
Photoshop a pretty lame but I sold them
and that's how I paid for like my
computer so I could get started with
YouTube and I wanted there's another one
I wanted to get started with YouTube
like two years before I actually started
before actually what YouTube was like I
wanted to make gaming videos my favorite
food is spicy food even if I cry on the
toilet the day after it's part of the
experience
my girlfriend knows more about football
and cars than me feel like these are
more secret confessions my favorite
number is 20 when I was a kid I always
won with number 20 I don't know it's
it's been my lucky number since as long
as I can remember I am one point 95
centimeters tall I was brought up by
ducks it's true I swear once I once I
find something that I alone I get so
nerdy in it like I'll I'll do it
non-stop which I think it's kind of like
YouTube happen actually yeah I actually
don't swear a lot outside of playing
horror games
I rarely swear I'm actually scared of
thunder all right that was way quicker
than I thought
but I think it'll be good it'll be fun
for you to figure out what what is right
and what is wrong you can just leave a
comment hello
focus [ __ ] thank you I only have
to do is leave a comment you get a
chance to win the beforehand this I just
want to remind you bro that the charity
for my my charity water is still going
on where add one hundred ninety three
thousand dollars right now which is
mind-blowing seriously thank you bro so
much all of you who participated I know
a lot of people can donate so literally
anyone who watched a video participating
their donation I had already made my
donation if you want proof of it I'll
leave a link in the description I know
people tend to be stupid on the internet
and be skeptic about it that happened
last times I just want to make sure I
have done it so you bros know last but
not least I just want to say thank you
both for everything I know it sounds
cheesy but I always think your bra's but
I wouldn't be anywhere without you and
to be to have come so far and we need
this channel that we can support so it's
such awesome charities that just means
so much to me I I can't thank you enough
so I'm gonna keep thanking you until
you're like what the hell
unsubscribe don't ever unsub x game good
anyway as a thank you we're gonna end it
with a brofist stay awesome dress
what healthier joy oh my god run oh my
hand was the [ __ ] out the divine